[Musik]
alle lieben wir machen heute einen
notweg blechkuchen das werden wie soll
ich sie überhaupt denn ich weiß es gar
nicht ich möchte jetzt nicht dickmann
zuschnitten nähe so richtig sie nicht
nennen
es sind ich glaube stracciatella
schnitten weil wir nehmen also etwa so
dickmanns weil ich die noch übrig hatte
meine schwester hatte geburtstag hat so
viel eingekauft und hat mir dann
mitgegeben von rezept und die schokolade
die in der außenhülle hier sich befindet
die wird gleich zerstückelt und dann
haben wir so eine art stracciatella
creme aber als allererstes nehme ich ihr
die waffe weg die brauchen wir jetzt
nicht für die cremt die werde ich aber
nicht wegschmeißen
die kommt hier zu meinen anderen keksen
für den boden dazu sage ich euch dabei
gleich noch was so und ich mache das
hier viel geredet wenn ich gerade weil
ich erledige das hirn dann sehen wir uns
gleich wieder die zu tun
die zutaten findet ihr wie immer in der
video beschreibung hier unter dem titel
[Musik]
so hier unten habe ich jetzt karamell
kekse da könnte ich jetzt auch
butterkekse oder kakao keksen und hier
oben die waffeln weil ich einfach nicht
verschwinden wollte
so und jetzt muss ich das ganze und gibt
der geschmolzene butter dazu das ist
quasi der no big boden fertig und ich
habe jetzt hier meinen ba kram und ich
mache das ganz gerne so dass ich meinen
eckigen torten retter als boden benutze
er könnte den bug raum jetzt auch direkt
auf eine platte auf irgendeine serviert
platte legen das ist auch kein problem
aber schon sagt mega praktisch ich hab
den griff ich kann das direkt anfassen
und in den kühlschrank tun und und
verlinke ich euch auch unten in die
infobox
ich habe jetzt meinen ba kram auf circa
22 x 24 cm eingestellt ein paar
zentimeter unterschied das ist überhaupt
kein problem gerade weil sinopec
geschichten nicht so und jetzt gebe ich
den boden einmal hier in die backform
und drückt den schönen fest an
[Musik]
dem boden ganz gut zur seite legen ich
zeig euch jetzt die schnelle creme dafür
nehme ich mich hier die schaumküsse
dickmanns in einer schüssel werde sie
jetzt richtig schön mit meinem touch in
ein bisschen klein drücken und da gebe
ich dann quark dazu ich nehme zu
magerquark könntet auch so dass für den
20 prozentigen nehmen das wäre gar kein
problem und ich nehme gleich auch noch
schmandt dazu und vanille extrakt und
dann muss ich erst mal nach dem
geschmack schauen ob sie überhaupt noch
puderzucker brauche weil die deckmantel
der schon sehr süß
[Musik]
zwei mal probieren süß genug also gerade
so richtig der quark nimmt so diese
extreme süße von den dickmanns perfekt
jetzt finde ich das noch so ein bisschen
mit salat und eines league revanche und
fertig und ich hab noch nicht mal eine
maschine gebraucht also anfänger
freundlich freundlich für menschen die
vielleicht eine küchenmaschine haben
perfekt ohne strom also man spare geld
bei dem rezept
[Musik]
ich muss noch mal betont ich liebe diese
winkel palette die wurde exakt nach
meinen vorstellungen kreiert die habe
ich mit entwickelt und die kommt immer
so gut vorne mit der spitze an den
backen und hinten mit dem winkel
jetzt habe ich das perfekt verstrichen
jetzt kommt das aber in den kühlschrank
für mindestens 4 studium gerne auch über
nacht also ihr könnt doch länger drin
lassen wir haben jetzt 17 uhr
deshalb würde ich mal sagen bevor wir
120 euro weiter film hamza machen wir
für heute schluss und dann seht ihr uns
morgen einfach wird also bei mir kommt
jetzt die ganze nacht in den kühlschrank
und dann lasse ich mir um ehrlich zu
sein noch was einfallen ich überlege
gerade mache ich ein schoko abschluss
mache ich einen früchte abschluss
überlege ich mir bis morgen ist wir
bringen dieses rezept ist übrigens sehr
spontan entstanden und mit zutaten die
ich einfach zu hause hatte da seht ihr
mal
es kann auch wirklich einfach sein und
mit ganz ganz einfachen mitteln auf
relativ genau also wir sehen uns dann
morgen einen tag später ich habe mich
jetzt für eine schokoglasur entschieden
eine mischung aus vollmilch und weißer
kuvertüre die habe ich bei niedriger
wattzahl ganz einfach in der mikrowelle
geschmolzen und damit das gleich nicht
so klappt sondern sich ganz schön
geschmeidig durchschneiden ist gebe ich
dann noch ein bisschen kokosfett dazu
also ganz einfach einrühren und dann
hoffe ich dass ich ein schönes muster
hinkriegt
[Musik]
im nächsten schritt die glasur kurz
trocknen lassen das dauert keine zehn
minuten dann den bug formloser nehmen
den rand schön herauslösen und jetzt
nämlich den bug ram einmal weg soll die
klemmung lösen und ich finde dass das
rezept echt mega schnell ging gucken so
ja schön sehr schön ist gucken wir auf
der geschmackstest dann auch bestanden
ist denn wenn nicht dann wird dieses
video niemals erscheinen aber ich glaube
da schmeckt ich glaube das schmeckt
immer halt kurz die letzten szenen und
dann schneide ich ihn an und dann
probiere ich wir beide probieren
[Musik]
die cos 0 wir haben viel probiert
zusammen nein haben so wären gesagt wir
probieren zusammen bis jetzt vor
laufender kamera gesprochen
die kämpfen die das stativ ist die
kamera ablaufen okay wir verkosten jetzt
unsere schnitte zum ersten mal stich ich
bin ich jetzt ohne erwartungen daran
okay hier du kannst von hier das stück
abmachen bin richtig gespannt was das
ist ein big points oder das ist das ein
big bands schnitt sagt dickmanns
schnitten werden oder habt ihr andere
vorschläge und wie schmeckt ich bin so
hummer oder so ein bisschen sorgen
den quark aber der schmeckt jetzt nicht
schwer also der springt jetzt nicht so
dass nur der haut richtig auf den hüften
das tut er bestimmt nicht richtig gut
ich bin glücklich der eindeutige beweis
kuchen macht immer glücklich hashtag
gibt also ich bin dafür dass du dein
stück kriegst und ich das stück weil
ganz ehrlich das stück teilen muss und
dann ist mein stück ist auf instagram
bisschen flotter und die leute ein
bisschen heiß drauf machen jetzt kannst
du gut
habe ich das richtig fies auf instagram
ich noch mal habt ihr dazu
ok unbedingt nachmachen das video geht
somit online
es bleibt nicht im roggen der schmeckt
sehr gut ich würde auch nichts dran
ändern
denkt bitte daran dass ihr im
kühlschrank gast und kurz vorm servieren
es raus holt das einzige was wir euch
als tipp geben kann also ganz viel spaß
beim nachmachen kann so durchaus zu
abonnieren
das auto herausschneiden
[Musik]